good morning believe nation today's
message is it's possible over the UC era
[Music]
I hope to inspire others and for people
to know that dreams are really real you
know I wasn't raising this every mistake
every performance I've done pretty much
happen from the world or like I kid you
not I wasn't I didn't grow up doing
singing in churches I didn't go doing
anything but I had a dream to do this
and I as soon as I put my mind to it and
said this is what I want to do I wrote
it down on paper and I kid you not
everything manifest that everything fell
in place so I feel like my experience
can't encourage anybody to know that
don't matter what time you know you
could be later on in your time and you
figure out what you want to do it's
possible so I hope to inspire the
difference between whether you achieve
your goals are not quite often is
whether you believe you can or not
there's a famous Henry Ford quote
whether you believe you can you can't
you're right and quite often what we do
is we don't listen to ourselves we
listen to the people around us whenever
you come up with a new idea what's the
thing that we like to do we like to tell
people that I would tell their friends
or tell their family and quite often
they tell us it's a stupid idea why are
you doing this you didn't go to school
for this you don't have the money to do
this and all of the limiting beliefs are
come in but then hold you back from
doing the thing that you think is
possible and sometimes it's out of
jealousy because they tried to do
something and it never took off for them
and so you're not allowed to do it
sometimes out of love because they don't
see the world the same way that you see
the world what's most important though
is that if you're taking advice from
somebody it's somebody who's done what
you're trying to do you know if your
parents or your friends and the people
who are saying all those reasons why
it's not going to work out but they've
never done what you're trying to do
their advice isn't helpful to you and
much more important you want anybody's
opinion of you is is what is your
opinion of yourself if you can create
the environment and the routine and the
regimen and the schedule to believe that
the crazy idea that you have in here is
possible then you will align everything
in your life to make it happen
if you believe you're going to go off
and build a million-dollar company and
you believe it then it doesn't matter
what everybody else around you says and
they laugh at your lack of experience
and they laugh at the idea and they
laugh at everything that's coming out of
your mouth it doesn't matter if you
believe it and so that's the most
important thing it doesn't matter what
are the people around you are saying
what matters is what you're saying to
yourself and I get that off and that's
that's a battle one day you're energized
are you telling yourself you can do
anything in another day you're down on
yourself I think it's important to be
hard on yourself but not to kick
yourself down but rather kick yourself
forward if you kick yourself down you're
just negative and I'm no good I'm never
going to amount to anything then you
won't but if you kick yourself forward
to say okay this project wasn't good I
know I can do better I know I can work
harder I know I have the ability to make
something great and that was just okay
and to work to achieve that goal and to
create that environment so that every
day you wake up and feel that that big
goal you have is possible because people
have done it people who look like you
with less resources have gone on and
done amazing things there's no excuse
why you can't go out and do something
equally amazing except the one that you
are telling yourself so the question is
the day today is what is the excuse
you're telling yourself about why it's
not possible leave it down the comments
below super curious to find out I also
want to give a quick shout out to Lynn
Poe deti Lynn thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book through one
word it really really really means a lot
to me and I hope you are enjoying the
route so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you guys again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
Oh give me go
I want you to look at something right
now thank you some major goal you want
or maybe it's one you're already working
on and you have experienced a lot of
setbacks a lot of defeats you've
experienced a lot of disappointment
maybe you've already given up and maybe
you just need a little fire a little
encouragement to get back in the game
again here's what I want you to look at
they're winners they're losers and there
are people who have not discovered how
to win and all they need is some
coaching all they need is some help and
assistance just a little support all
they need is some insight or a different
strategy a plan of action to make some
adjustments that will open up the key to
a whole new future for them that will
give them access to the unlimited power
that they have within themselves that's
all that they need so what I want you to
do is think about something you want for
you that's real for you that's important
for you that will give your life some
special meaning and power and I don't
even want you to say I can do that I
don't want you to assume that see five
years ago when I started out in this
area I would not have been able to make
the mental leap that I would be up to
where I am right now I don't want you to
begin to just psych yourself out no no I
want you to be able to say something to
yourself that will enable you to
maintain a level of integrity with
yourself that when you say this even
when you face tremendous setbacks it it
will be a benchmark to keep you in the
game to keep you moving forward and
experimenting and readjusting your
strategy and your plan of action
continuously looking for ways to win so
what is that something when you got an
idea you want to move on you might not
have the money you might not have the
education you might not have the support
of the resources you need what is that
something that can keep us going that
will enable us to act on our dream
what's one of those keys that will begin
to help us to discover the secrets to
our dream here's what I want you to
repeat after me please
with power and conviction say it's
possible that's all I want you to do
when you look at your dream you say to
yourself every day it's possible yes say
that every day to them it's possible
because what does that do see it begins
to change your belief system see the way
in which we operate ladies and gentlemen
it's a manifestation of what we believe
what's possible for us whatever you've
done up to this point all that it really
is is a duplication it's a reproduction
of what you believe subconsciously that
you deserve and what's possible for your
life before in April 1954 the common
belief the universal belief because it
had been tried again and again and again
and people have failed the belief was
that man was not physically capable of
breaking the four-minute barrier that he
could not run a mile in less than four
minutes that was the belief on the
planet it had never been done but here's
what happened ladies and gentlemen Roger
Bannister came along and he broke the
four-minute barrier now here's what's
significant about that since that time
up to this day over 20,000 people have
done it including high school kids what
change 20,000 people what changed here's
what happened when they got on the track
they knew it had been done and because
they knew it had been done there was a
new belief about this barrier about this
goal that was unreachable and those
20,000 people got an a' raised believing
knowing in the heart that someone had
done it that it's possible that they
could do it and i'm saying that if you
know anybody that had some goal some
dreams something they wanted to do and
they did it denies things that you know
in your heart that if someone has
turn it then you can do it it's possible
and that if someone can make that dream
become a reality that it's it's possible
that you can make your dream become
reality in only 21 years cunning zach
has come from nowhere to be one of the
highest regarded hyper car manufacturers
being counted alongside Ferrari
Lamborghini and McLaren how would they
pulled that off well we had to work hard
be a little bit innovative and don't
believe in the hype that it's impossible
but it's you know every day we we strive
and push and and learn and adapt and
when you do that for 20 years with a
great focus within the group you can do
pretty much anything I think that's the
simple answer but for sure it's not easy
you have to be prepared to work hard for
it